[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings here at 8
30. we have an unusual segment for this
time of the morning because unusual
things are going on in eastern europe
ukraine appears to be on the brink of a
full scare full-scale war after russian
president vladimir putin announced
yesterday he has sent troops into
breakaway areas of the country
possible russian military vehicles have
been spotted in those territories and
president biden is expected to announce
more sanctions against russia today for
more on all of it i want to bring in
senator marco rubio he is a member of
the senate foreign relations committee
and vice chairman of the senate select
committee on intelligence senator rubio
good morning to you we're being a little
bit careful in our language because
we're not sure what is going on there on
those uh on the border of ukraine and
russia but you have said the invasion
has begun and the worst has yet to come
so walk us through your vision of what
putin wants here and i gather it goes
beyond just recognizing these two
so-called breakaway regions
yeah these these so-called breakaway
regions and the people who run them they
don't just claim the areas that they
currently possess they claim areas that
are currently under the power of kiev
and so what's going to happen here is
russia is going to send in their troops
to the areas that those two separatist
regions control but they're going to
move in on those areas that kiev
currently controls because they claim
those too and when kiev fights back then
they're going to say that
that violates you know that that that's
going to trigger the
mutual defense agreement that putin
signed yesterday with this fake new
country and he's going to move in on
those areas as well you want my personal
view and it's been this way for over a
month and a half i think he takes
basically the entire east of the country
and that includes i think he takes the
capital or he'll try anyways i think
ukrainians are going to fight back but
this is going to have an impact on
americans even though it seems to be
really far away
so what can america and the
international community do we expect
sanctions later today sanctions were not
effective in 2014 when it came to russia
taking crimea what hope is there for
them today
well i don't believe the sanctions are
going to stop them from doing what their
plan is but i do think there has to be
if you don't pay a price for doing this
he's going to do more of it if you
listen to that speech yesterday the
argument he used
for why invading ukraine the old soviet
rules you could make that argument about
any of the baltic states who were all
who are now all members of nato and many
of those baltic states were actually
part of the you know the old russian
empire even longer than ukraine you
could use the same argument to take
those so uh he he's not going to stop
with ukraine if he's allowed he must pay
a big price for it but i also think
we've got to return for example to our
own domestic energy production as a
matter of national security emergency
now because russia and this disruption
that this is going to create is going to
increase oil prices and we're going to
feel it at the pump here in america and
that by the way will increase the prices
on everything because everything that we
buy and sell is transported by something
that's burning gas and diesel
yeah i wanted to pick up on that senator
because you just said it will have an
effect on america even though it's very
far away can you elaborate exactly what
you mean because i think when we're
sitting here in this country our main
concern is covet our main concern are
empty shelves and escalating prices can
you really break it down why this is
important and why we should be paying
attention and care about this
sure i'll focus on four things the first
as i said is the price of oil the price
of oil the barrel goes up to 110 115
that's we're going to feel that at the
pump okay the second thing is um these
are things people don't think about
ukraine is one of the world's largest
agricultural producers the fourth
largest i believe in wheat fifth largest
in corn that's going to raise global
food prices which eventually impact us
because you know when somebody gets cut
off of that they're now they become our
competitors in the global market for
food costs the third is something a lot
of people don't think about neon gas
ukraine is the world's leading producer
of neon gas which is critical to the
production of semiconductors ninety
percent of the neon gas used to make
semiconductors in america something
there's a shortage of already uh comes
from ukraine if that's disrupted or cut
off we're going to really struggle with
i remember back in 2014 when when that
invasion happened it really increased
the price of the semiconductors you can
see now where that's playing out in our
economy and even our by the way our
space industry this this could
potentially
the russia piece of it being cut off
from russian pieces we still depend on
russia for key components of many of our
commercial launches you could begin to
see launches this year scrapped things
that are critical to both national
security and also our commercial
viability senator you believe that a
full-scale invasion war is inevitable
you also tweeted yesterday weakness
always invites aggression so what should
the biden administration do if you
believe that a full-scale invasion is
happening
well they should have treated yesterday
as a full-scale invasion i hope that's
what they'll do today last night they
seemed to indicate that them moving into
areas controlled by separatists is just
based as public acknowledgement of what
already was true and so i didn't think
that was an appropriate response but i
think beyond that if you look at one of
the things that gave putin the belief
that now is the time to act it's the
price of energy around the world global
oil prices and the decision in the
united states to make it harder to do
oil and natural gas exploration has
contributed to those higher prices which
in turn has empowered him in an ironic
way that even though this crisis is
going to create higher oil prices that
benefits putin and it's his leverage we
will see he believes that the europeans
who depend on him heavily for their
energy sources oil and natural gas will
not be able to sustain sanctions against
him for long because of energy prices
and so it was a big mistake to sort of
make it harder to do exploration we
became energy independent in 2018 we
need to go back to that
senator uh you know it's not lost on me
that the last republican president uh
believed and it was a popular belief
that america cannot be the world's
policeman you've never taken that
position yourself but at this juncture
in time i am curious to know should
americans be prepared for
for contact between
the russians and the u.s military is it
going to come to that
well it shouldn't because a war between
the us and russia is not going to be
good for anybody these are the two the
world's two largest nuclear powers and
that's one of the things even as we are
firm in our response we have to try
everything possible to avoid because
they can escalate very quickly we're not
the world's policemen we're not sending
troops into ukraine
but we can't our number one priority is
our national interest our national
interest is impacted by what's happening
there and i outlined some of the reasons
why and there are others from a
geopolitical perspective and i would
just say this if kobet taught us
anything it's that something that
happens and starts halfway around the
world can reach you know main street
america pretty quickly
obviously this is not at that scale but
it's important enough to care about it
what's your advice to american citizens
watching you right now we've been
hearing about this for several weeks
it's coming it's coming it's coming no
it's not now it's here what's your
advice to people listening to you
well let me see look i mean
i think first of all pray for your
leaders and pray for ukraine that people
make some wise choices this is a moment
of high tension because there is the
possibility the danger of escalation i
think russia is going to respond with
cyber of some level which which in turn
would require response from us and you
fear that escalation could lead to the
kind of active combat that you're
talking about or mentioned a moment ago
which would be you know just incredibly
dangerous this is a very tense and
dangerous moment you have nato fully
mobilized you have the largest you know
land army and since world war ii massed
by the russians they're operating within
very close distance proximity of one
another so this is a moment of high
tension it's a moment for some sobriety
we have to respond strong but we also
have to be smart at the same time and
avoid unnecessary
and needless escalation because that
would become
catastrophic it is a careful balance
we're looking at what could be the
biggest ground war in europe since world
war ii senator marco rubio thank you
very much
hey thanks for having me on